[تصفيق]
تعود الروايه الفلسطينيه من بعيد لتفرض
نفسها بقوه في شوارع العواصم الغربيه التي
اعتاد غالبيه ساستها على الانحياز الكامل
للروايه
الاسرائيليه في الايام الاولى التي تلت
هجوم السابع من اكتوبر بدا المشهد وكان
وسائل الاعلام الكبرى في الغرب نجحت في
استماله الراي العام خصوصا حين تبنت
الادعاءات الاسرائيليه بكل حذافيرها بشان
جرائم مزعومه ارتكبت بحق اطفال ونساء في
مستوطنات غلاف غزه لكن طوفان الصور
الصادمه القادمه من القطاع التي وجدت
طريقا على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي سرعان
ما لاقى صدا واسعا في المجتمعات الغربيه
ودفعت كثيرين للنزول للشوارع والتعبير عن
غضبهم تجاه ما يعتبرونه جرائم اباده
جماعيه ومجازر وحشيه ترتكبها اسرائيل على
مدار الساعه
[تصفيق]
حاولت بعض السلطات والحكومات الغربيه لا
سما من تبنت بشكل كامل السرديه
الاسرائيليه فرض قيود على التظاهر واشكال
التعبير وصولا لمحاوله حظر رفع العلم
الفلسطيني ووسم المسيرات المؤيده لاهالي
غزه بانها مسيرات كراهيه ومعاد للساميه
لكن ذلك لم يحل دون تمدد المظاهرات وتزايد
اعداد المشاركين فيها لتصل روتها الى حشود
بمئات الالاف في عاصمتي الدولتين الاكثر
دعما للحكومه الاسرائيليه لندن وواشنطن
كما شهدت غالبيه المدن الكبرى في اوروبا
والولايات المتحده مسيرات ووقفات احتجاجيه
مندده بافعال اسرائيل وداعيه لوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار ما شكل ضغطا على حكوماتهم
وعلى مواقف نخبهم السياسيه في حين كشفت
استطلاعات للراي ما يمكن وصفه بتحول جذري
لدى شرائح واسعه في المجتمعات الغربيه
تجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه اذ يرى اكثر من
نصف الشباب الامريكيين ان الحل طويل الامد
للقضيه الفلسطينيه هو بزوال اسرائيل
واعاده الاراضي المحتله
للفلسطينيين كما اعرب نحو 60% ممن تراوح
اعمارهم بين 18 و34 عاما عن تاييده للراي
الذي يقول بان اسرائيل ترت اباده جماعيه
في غزه ويرى ناشطون فلسطينيون في الغرب ان
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وما رافقها من
كسر لكل المحرمات والقوانين الدوليه
وارتكاب فضائع وحشيه وقتل لالاف الاطفال
وقصف للمستشفيات وللسيارات الاسعاف وتشريد
نحو مليوني انسان اجبر كثيرين في الغرب
على رؤيه المشهد بعيون جديده وكانهم
يتعرفون على القضيه الفلسطينيه وعلى
الانسان الفلسطيني للمره الاولى في
حياتهم